the male's is a Garth fat ashton kutcher
churn country star this weekend in his
home town of Cedar Rapids Iowa and if
you open up a hole about home with ET
online so Keisha lacy for example cuz
baby girl Wyatt is talking up a storm or
should we say swearing up a storm nearly
comes into the bedroom is like puppy pee
down stairwell and I go and I walk away
like this and all of a sudden I hear
behind me and like in doing the same
exact walk it was this I just turn
around she's with Ginny like this and I
was like [ __ ] I said Fox the Papa said
Fox and she was like and I was like no
Fox
I said Fox yes that's box don't worry
now bad dad Aston isn't just teaching
Wyatt dirty words she also knows these
three let it go where did you get that
like I don't even know cuz she's got me
do you see her wanting to do in a show
biz no no do you think you would let her
pursue a career in show business I'm
doing everything I can't keep her away
from you guys
oh I had stayed home with grandparents
but mama pregnant Eva was there as
Ashton and former NFL player Dallas
Clark hosted the back porch revival
concert benefiting their native fun
organization the whole theme of it is
Iowans helping Iowans we're gonna do
some great things with it
Ashe is not the only one who's saying
this guy Blake Shelton also took the
stage girlfriend when was watching via
periscope former concert in California
and afterwards she celebrated these are
called jello shots I don't even drink
but I'm gonna try it
but Ashton has his own plans for Blake
like a guest starring role on his
Netflix show the wrench i watch the
voice all the time he's absolutely
fantastic I want whatever is in his cup
and but he seems like a great guy mom
heck yeah yeah I'd have him on in a
second